foreign
[Music]
ERS of Ramsay Solutions broadcasting
from the PODS moving and storage Studios
it's the Ramsay show where debt is dumb
cash is king and the paid off Home
Mortgage has taken the place of the BMW
as the status symbol of choice I'm Dave
Ramsey your host we help people build
wealth do work that they love and create
actual amazing relationships in spite of
having to spend time with your family
over Thanksgiving
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two five Dr John deloney
Ramsey personality host of the Dr John
deloney show number one best-selling
author of own your past change your
future is my co-host today we're going
to answer your questions you jump in the
phone number is triple eight eight two
five five two two five Benjamin is in
Atlanta hi Benjamin how are you
good how are you Dave better than I
deserve what's up
so I'm trying to figure out how much of
my salary I want to contribute to my
retirement plan I'm currently
contributing the recommended 15 to a
401K plan
um but I'm now working for a company
that gives a 200 match up to four
percent
so that's eight percent of my salary
that are putting into my 401k
and on top of that at the end of the
year they contribute another 10 to my
401k as profit sharing that's what they
put in does not count in our equation
well okay
what you put in 18 you would put in
15 of your household income into
retirement of baby step four
is that what you were you were
calculating the company in there
no I am right now I am putting 15 in and
my company's putting 18 in so that's a
total of 33 that's pretty phenomenal
you're going to be rich that's going
into my yeah it is pretty fantastic so
my question was
since uh since the match is so high on
top of my 15 can I afford to only
contribute 10 of my salary to a 401k and
put that extra five percent uh towards
saving up for a house and later paying a
monthly payment on a house
okay so you're you're trying to figure
out a house down payment not paying off
a house
correct okay
maybe maybe step 3B is saving for the
down payment that's what we call it
before you get to baby step four which
is 15 of your income going into
retirement now here's what people do and
that's okay with us because baby step 3B
is a temporary thing it's just while you
save a down payment that's all you're
doing okay and while you're doing that
some people don't even start baby step
four they do zero some people do up to
the match and some people do the full 15
and how fast can you save the down
payment that's a trick right so any
other anywhere in there you want to go
and it sounds like you know if you want
to back it down to 10 that's fine but
that is not me saying you live in a
house you own a house and you should
back down to 10 so you can put more on
your house mortgage and baby step six no
I am not saying that
that's for all the other listeners
that's not for you
okay but in your case you know in it
whether you got a match or whether you
didn't some people just choose to do
nothing some people choose to do match
the three percent and some want to go
ahead and do the 15 and just try to save
the down payment above that
um right you can do any of those is fine
because you shouldn't be saving for your
down payment longer than three years Max
okay how old are you
plan 24. wow what's your income
uh 68 000. dude if you stick with us
you're gonna be so rich John's right
this Benjamin at 24.
um I've had a couple of different places
where I've worked where they've had
incredible
matches like this and at least in my
after a couple of decades in the
workforce
every time it has shifted that that
overwhelming we're able to put this much
money it tends to be kind of a bonus is
the way that that people will look at it
so we're not going to add to your salary
because that's ongoing but we're gonna
do this every year those that has
whittled away in every job where I've
had that type of
of uh generosity and so don't build your
life expecting that to happen year over
year over here
build your life expecting you to have to
do it and anything your company does is
called gravy on the biscuit yeah if you
set that up emotionally John's right
then you're going to keep going uh
because you're not like oh well I can't
do it now because I don't get the match
no I felt like
um as a young guy I thought they were
taking something from me right like it
was hey we're able to do this we're able
to do this and then 2010 hit 2009 hit
and we got to back down some of our
retirement match well it felt like you
were taking something from me right and
it wasn't it was a cool thing they were
able to do during times of Plenty it was
generosity that's right and then it
couldn't yeah that's right but I built
my life as though you owed it to me and
that was on me not on them yeah but
that's also the way it has to do with
the narrative and the way you explain it
that's right yeah that's good good
question Benjamin you're doing great Max
proud of you way to go dude Angela is in
Los Angeles hi Angela welcome to the
Ramsey Show
hi Dave hi John I'm very happy to be on
good to have you how can we help thanks
um I just had a quick question or
exercise I need your advice
um so I found you guys back in May and I
was binge watch for months I binge
watched and finally I decided to call
for motivation because I was unhappy at
my job and I called George
and he kind of told me you know get
another job and I did so I put my resume
out and I got a call from a local
government job and they paid me about
twenty thousand dollars more than what I
had already with them when I was already
making dad come George is worth his
white and gold and he's a small guy
that's not a lot of weight but man good
for him
yeah he gave me the motivation I needed
to you know get out there so now I just
can't seem to get back on track to the
baby stuff that I'm struggling and when
I tell you I'm tired I'm tired of not
having enough money or at the end of the
month I'm exhausted and it's harder now
so you make more money and you're doing
a worse job handling it
yes exactly oh George George it's all
George's fault
so what what is what's your challenge
like you're making this new money why
yeah why did you get lazy then
I would have got more intense
I feel like I
I don't know
um a lot of changes at work you know
those few months that I started and I
feel like every time I get anxious now I
just
I spent
um
so yeah and I'll have more money to
spend and it's harder sorry you have
you're doing a lot of feeling
and here's why the baby steps are so
remarkable they take your feelings and
your thoughts out of the equation yeah
they take your feelings and they stomp
on your feet you just do what's the plan
you follow the plan like I don't feel
like working out it doesn't matter
here's the workout you're doing today I
don't feel like I feel like spending I
feel like getting online
um
who cares here's what's next in line and
so getting on a plan is really good for
this and you've got to adjust your
identity
you're somebody who really makes good
money now who does really well you are
not somebody who spins when they get
anxious and I want you to start there
and reverse engineer that life
okay does that make sense yeah stop
saying that's who you are because it's
really not who you are now you are yeah
who you are as a lady who makes 20 000
more than she used to because of George
that's right and then who you are as a
lady that's not managing it as well oh
wait no you're the lady that's starting
to manage it better as of today because
of John you're going to get on a plan so
there you go you're gonna get on a plane
yeah absolutely one of my buddies who's
a multi-millionaire said you know your
stuff started working when I submitted
myself to the plan
which powerful word it's a powerful word
it means the plan is going to kick your
butt this is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
look I love real estate and I want you
to have a house but I don't want a house
to have you that's why you need to get
in touch with Churchill Mortgage to make
sure you do this right these guys are
awesome they'll help you get on a
smarter mortgage plan because they're
committed to doing what's right for you
that means they check in every year with
free consultations to help you stay on
the right plan they show you how to save
money and interest so you can build
wealth faster they walk you through the
total cost of your loan so you can make
the best choice basically they care
that's why we call them Ramsey trusted
you can achieve debt-free home ownership
and Churchill is here to help go to
their site churchillmortgage.com Ramsey
to start your approval or get more
information
foreign
[Music]
personality is my co-host today number
one best-selling author well Black
Friday might be over but you've still
got plenty of names on your Christmas
list right well then check out all the
deals on our one day Cyber Monday sale
you can get our best seller sellers for
as low as five dollars if you're ready
to crush your goals see there it is John
crush your goals next year the 2023
Ramsey goal Crusher planner gold planner
will help you keep focused get organized
and crushing the new 2023 planner has
Ramsay's five essential guidelines for
goal setting so you can create specific
and measurable goals for your finances
relationships spiritual growth first
time ever it's on sale get yours before
they're gone of course this is set up
it's a full calendar it's a beautiful
book to you guide you through the whole
year and for your holiday get together
get your friends and family off their
screens with Dr John deloney's questions
for humans conversation cards they have
the New Year's deck the uh Christmas
deck sold out by the way these fun
conversation starters make connecting
with each other easy get everyone
talking with questions like this one if
we had to buy a plane ticket right now
for a trip together next year where
would we go home uh this is a season to
share hope and give generously we all
know that someone who's struggling today
with their money their relationships
we've got tons of deals on every single
best seller that we've had everything at
ramseysolutions.com shop the Cyber
Monday one day sale today
ramseysolutions.com hey I got one of
these cars I want to do with you the
question for humans for humans yes so if
you're presupposing I'm human okay
that's a good start no you can you can
you can use this with robots too okay
it's very good
um what two words would you use to sum
up this year and you can't say dumpster
fire
oh why not
oh no it wasn't a dumpster fire
sweet and sour sweet and sour how so I
got lots of sweetness lots of good
things happen and lots of sour things
lots of tough stuff yeah huh
except that's three words Joe Biden but
yeah
hey that is incredible
I got two words for you made in America
that was fantastic fantastic I love it
uh no matter hey no matter what happens
you're always that one family member
that can take any innocuous question and
bring it back to politics
well I use three words then I just sit
here and you didn't catch
it yeah what's one thing you become
obsessed with this year
hmm
this year
just this particular year uh more than
other years building projects I've got
about three things or four things coming
out of the ground right now and I keep
driving around looking at all of them
being built it's a lot of fun do you
like that oh man I'm like a little kid
with a dumpster with a dump truck yeah
when as soon as like they hand you the
keys and they do the cutting are you
already thinking about what I'm done I'm
done yeah yeah I was done before that
but I mean when it's done it's done but
that I love the planning and the coming
out of the ground and you know we've got
the new Ramsay Event Center and I'm
building a huge event barn on my farm
and a couple other little a couple other
little building projects and that's just
fun what about you what are you obsessed
with I mean I was just thinking about
what I got obsessed with this year
um
this was the first year that things kind
of settled in here at work and because
there's a whole new craft for me
learning something completely new like
how radio works and interviews work and
podcasts work so this year was the first
year I really got intent on trying to
learn how to do the craft not just
survive right so the way I describe it
to my friends over Thanksgiving was when
you're skiing and you first are learning
and you're coming when the boat takes
off and you're just getting blasted with
water and then there's a moment you get
on top of it and you're just excited to
be on top of the water but you're
holding on tight and this year was the
first year
I got comfortable on top of the water
now we can figure out how to do this
thing so that's another metaphor I love
with us you know the first year I went
snow skiing and I wasn't sore oh man
yeah I like that that's fantastic
because I wasn't using every muscle in
my body to stand up
snow skiing that's one thing other than
golf I don't understand but that's a
that's a different that's a different
different subject I thought you were
gonna say deer hunting with your son
that's been he's old enough now he's 12.
it's like it's like a thing now we spent
they're hunting and then there's deer
hunting with your son yes and then
there's we spent eight hours in the
woods yesterday and then eight hours the
day before nothing and to see a 12 year
old boy knows even I was like back there
looking at my phone just to sit for
eight hours
I thought me and his mom are doing
something right and he just was patient
and then we got in the car and he's
disappointed he's like we'll get him
next time Dad and so it's teaches you
these lessons of patience and of uh all
these cool cool moments that you get to
spill on your son so it's been great
that's cool yeah not a chance I could do
that oh man I would be a nervous wreck
it was pretty hours and [ __ ] there just
sit there just wait to shoot myself just
waiting hey here's a here's pretty neat
when it's six hours and all of a sudden
a deer comes up and it's the wrong size
or it's too far away yeah this is that's
not neat at all and watch a 12 to watch
a 12 people who go fishing and don't
catch fish patience no I go catching I
don't go fishing building character it's
not character perseverance and all that
stuff wrong weapons courses wrong
weapons it's a mile away I'll get him
get the 50 cal oh my gosh yeah you want
to do that Dave I know I know get the
hate mail get it going people get it
going come on uh yeah we're just talking
about shooting Bambi so there you go
it's all over now the pita people can
line up
oh all right there we go that's
questions for human cards
controversy and politics always you're
just gonna love these cards people
they're gonna be they're going to be
endearing there's ones for dating for
friends for family get-togethers for
kids schools if you're a teacher want to
create hate mail and trolls I do I I
have proposed that one
um I want to have one that end like a
friendship Ender that's just Trump is
the smartest man alive true or false I
just want to like we're gonna put those
things out on the table we're gonna
divide friendships up so so good
um lots of shaming questions
and a mass saved America true or false
they're gonna be faint vaccination one
two three four booster so good yeah yeah
you're gonna find out hey you know what
we're probably we weren't gonna make it
as a friend group so we're gonna call it
now or if you really want to break up
with somebody I don't really fit in
these are the man these are the cards
for you these are the cards for you you
could have the most obnoxious questions
that would be yeah we really can't do
that because it would probably cause
trouble but and we're here to bring hope
and joy and peace and yeah but but
sometimes hope and joy and peace comes
with uh separation that's right
boundaries
all right imagine people don't even know
what this is okay these are cards it
looks like a deck of cards that's right
and they've got conversation starters
and none of them are snarky are
sarcastic or political no there's no
politics there's no covets in them we
put no covids in these at all you can't
get covered from it and you can't talk
about covid because of it okay as a
matter of fact it keeps your crazy butt
relatives who talked about it all
through Thanksgiving dinner from dealing
with you have to no we can't talk about
that we talk about this and you throw a
card down that's right and then you can
say what's something you're obsessed
with this year and you can't say covet
and I will say this my daughter
Josephine I left a a deck of the parents
kids
she brings it to dinner every night she
wants to get the cars wants to get the
cards and we've even answered some of
the same ones again she wants to do it
again she wants to do it again and I
think her body is telling her hey this
is a way Mom and Dad plug in directly
with me like this is a way we're all at
the table together
um despite our best efforts and so
um we played Monopoly they're great for
kids oh see I get too competitive with
Monopoly
get too competitive
oh the one that kills me is The Game of
Life
because it's not
and it's also got credit cards in it now
you can get a credit card with the game
of life so Game of Life I'm so it was
it's like how do you tell people when
you were born in the 14th century
without telling them yeah you mentioned
the Game of Life yeah that's it
when did that game come out oh God man
it had to be the 60s or 70s
I mean I had like I said when I was a
kid I know I'm scared so back when there
was dinosaurs roaming there
little short arms on the back of the
covered wagon y'all would play Life yeah
very cool when we were going across the
Prairie this may have been the greatest
sales pitch segment of our our careers
yeah I'm saying that black Friday can't
top Cyber Monday after that
if nothing else we've sold out of all
the questions for human cards ever made
go save your families and go get them
yeah it is a lot of fun it's almost as
much fun as John and I have just
babbling about nothing and blowing an
entire segment this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
good
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
we were drawn to Christian Healthcare
Ministries because we both had young
families and we wanted to have more
children and we had also just started a
real estate company and needed to find
Health Care coverage that would meet our
needs we were attracted to chm because
of its low monthly costs and the ability
to negotiate medical costs down
established in 1981 and accredited by
the Better Business Bureau chm is here
to meet the needs of your growing family
your small business check us out at
chministries.org backslash budget we
absolutely believe in it
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
Ramsey personality is my co-host today
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two five this is the
Ramsay show Christine is with us in
Cheyenne Wyoming hi Christine how are
you
great how are you doing better than I
deserve what's up
um thank you so much for taking my call
so my husband and I are new listeners of
yours and
um we're on baby steps fourth I've been
six we have no doubt except for our
mortgage good but we're concerned that
our mortgage is a bit High
um it doesn't quite follow your ratios
so I just wanted to talk that through
with you and see us we should keep going
online or make a change
okay in this case our ratios uh
don't matter as much in the case of
mortgage payment as a percentage of your
income as why we have the ratios now
that matters a lot okay the why is
simply uh if you use up all your money
on your house payment you don't have any
money it's called House poor
right
and that will cause you with if you if
you're living with a super high house
payment even though you're already out
of debt and you're baby step four five
and six it'll keep you from investing
long term keep you from your generosity
goals and it in some cases if it's super
high if for people people feel forced uh
to take a car payment because they don't
save up for a car because I don't have
any room to save up for a car or
something like that so that's the reason
we tell people to not get a super high
house payment like most of the culture
tells you to do but and so once you kind
of understand that then you can kind of
back into your particulars
and say you know okay what do we what
are we violating on the 25 of your
take-home pay on a 15-year fixed and um
and how is that going to be okay given
that we don't want to be house poor so
how much is your house payment
3 900
say again
3 900.
and your monthly take-home pay is
11 000.
okay so you're about 34 percent
right okay and um
what do you guys do for a living
uh my husband is in supply chain is what
and I say he's in supply chain and I
stay home with our kids
supply chain oh God I can't hear okay
um supply chain
all right and uh
he's killing it
um
so
how many raises now because the last two
years don't count what do you guys feel
like the trajectory of his income is
is it going to go up substantially in
the next three years
I think so which makes this conversation
not needed moot right
okay yeah because I mean if it goes from
33 to 28 to 25 percent with three raises
because your house payment stays the
same and your income goes up then we're
not worried about you being house poor
long term correct
correct yeah so that that's one fix for
this but if you had two wild years based
on supply chain backup and he crushed it
and he's going to settle back into 9 000
a month now you got a problem exactly
so what are you looking at on his income
do you think
I think it'll go out
I think it'll go down if it goes down
you need to reevaluate this house
okay if it as long as it is has an
upward trajectory in the next 36 to 48
months you're not going to be stuck
there with all your money going to a
house payment and not being able to fund
your kids college fund
or having an air conditioner break and
you got to get it go to a credit union
to get to be able to pay for it right
right emergency fine that's right that's
right yeah so just don't get yourself to
where you're there that's the whole
point of the thing you see uh and yeah
so you don't you don't need Ramsay to
tell you how to manage your life you
just but you but A good rule period
whether Ramsay's in your uh discussion
or not is don't be house poor don't have
a house payment that takes up all your
money makes you broke and so uh but I
think you sound like you're okay it's
not ideal if you were getting ready to
buy a home I would tell you to back off
don't be so house uh you know but you're
there I wouldn't tell you to move over
this you're not trapped and hopelessly
mathematically disabled you know
so I wouldn't tell you to do that but uh
but you don't have any room it's got to
go up you can't go back and you don't
have any wiggle room because if it gets
if it goes down much it stays down very
long you're going to be forced into a
different property but right now I think
you got a lot of house and in Cheyenne
Wyoming it's a big freaking house
that's a big dog right there well done
good for you I bet it's fun Michael's
with us Michael is in West Virginia
Huntington to be exact hey Michael
what's up
not much Dave how are you better than we
deserve how can we help right hey uh
real quick before my question I just
wanted to tell you I've been at a cycle
of years since 2006 someone bought me
The Total Money Makeover and I followed
it ever since and about 10 years ago I
met my wonderful beautiful wife and I
was very pleased to find out she's a
disciple of yours as well the only
problem is she hadn't really heard of
you she had been following your your uh
your idea she was a follower of Common
Sense Common Sense Common Sense the
Bible and your grandparents as you say
Obviously so I just wanted to tell you
that because it was a match made in half
and the two of us and and we've followed
your plan and we still we still follow
the principles but thank you you'll
laugh when I when I preface this but
this is a Thanksgiving weekend uh
discussion kind of question that I'm
going to pose to you and you and Dr John
so I had a grandmother pass away about
10 years ago and for the most part her
estate has been essentially distributed
and everything was fine there we found
out kind of recently that one of the
things that has not been dealt with was
a a diamond ring that was given to her
by her father-in-law it's not an
engagement ring it was just a diamond
ring that she's held in her possession
her verbal wishes uh as she was you know
getting up in years was that the ring
was to be sold and the proceeds from
that were to be divided evenly among the
families she has three daughters uh we
all get along well everyone loves each
other everything is happy and no one's
really in any any dire Financial
straights no one really really needs the
money but the issue is now what do we do
with the ring and as I was talking with
some family over the weekend one of the
suggestions was to go ahead and sell it
we understand that it appraised for
about eighteen thousand dollars don't
know that it'll sell for that let's be
conservative and say that it'll sell for
10. uh there are family members that may
want the ring but that kind of goes
against what our grandmother's wishes
were to do with the ring uh as she
passed away and then kind of a third
option which we're not sure if this
would even work would be to actually cut
up the ring and we're told that that
could be a very risky proposition and
you know know what you're going to get
from the ring so in any event I just
want to hear your thoughts I know you've
talked a lot about what people their
wishes and as they're passing on and I
just wanted to hear kind of your idea
for or your thoughts on what would be a
good idea
you know and these things I try to just
switch moccasins and walk in your
grandmother's shoes a minute
and go if I if I was if it was me what
would I care you know so this is not a
uh
a Sentimental thing it was not her
wedding ring it was not
um something like that it was simply a a
piece of jewelry that's valuable that
she owned exactly that's all it was so
there's not a lot of emotion to it
um so uh you know I I don't think it's
it from what you described to me it
doesn't sound inconsistent if you guys
had it appraised and you know one sister
wanted it and the other two bought her
out for the other two-thirds or even for
a discounted amount let's say we got it
appraised I think we can actually sell
it for 15.
um but hey you know the other two
sisters will take four instead of five
each and that kind of thing and just buy
each other out and let one of them that
wants it have it I don't think that's
inconsistent
and you put and you put some extra
stipulations on your what your grandma
said she didn't say if anybody is in
dire need of cash sell this thing she
said sell it and you'll split it so just
because y'all aren't starving or broke
or in desperate need of money right now
doesn't mean that we're not gonna do
what she said right sure exactly and and
Dave what you suggested it sounds great
but it just feels kind of slimy to us uh
but we think that may be the best the
best solution I don't think it's slimy
at all I don't hear any slime in it at
all if everybody's in agreement to it
now if it creates an argument then there
might be some slime there but if Sister
a wants it and B and C want to be bought
out at a slight discount below what
it'll actually bring I think that's a
generous thing for everyone what slimy
is if Sister a wants it and thinks well
she's going to get it for free yeah
that's taking advantage of Grandma yeah
and then the other two get nothing yeah
that would be a little weird but yeah
just buy them out that's um it's not an
unusual thing in our states by the way
this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
Dr John deloney host of the Doctor John
deloney show number one best-selling
author Ramsay personality is my co-host
today our question of the day comes from
blinds.com they have a 100 satisfaction
guarantee that means even if you miss
measure you mess up you pick the wrong
color you mess up like I have uh they'll
remake your window blinds for free it's
a you screwed up guarantee yeah you get
free samples free shipping and new
promos all the time you'll save even
more always use the promo code Ramsay
It's Magic you'll get a better deal all
right today's question comes from
Melissa in Wisconsin she says I've been
following the baby steps and I'm very
proud of how I've grown financially and
personally I have no debt and I'm saving
for retirement during college the
relationship with one of my parents
became very strained and that parent
took out a twenty thousand dollar Sallie
Mae student loan without consulting
other family members this parent is the
only person on the loan and my name is
not on it I know legally I'm not
obligated to pay it back but morally
what are your opinions on me paying it
back to this parent we've been estranged
for years due to other circumstances and
I used the money in college for books
and room and board I've tried to consult
other close Christian friends and my
counselor who did not think I am
obligated to pay it back since this
person has made very poor financial
decisions multiple bankruptcies and is
not respected boundaries with me what
are your thoughts
poof
I've got
I'll start you start you're you're
stuttering yes you're standing I've got
a strong feeling a lot of thoughts I do
um okay let me there's a lot of a lot of
different words we can use here
I would agree with your counselor
that you are not obligated to pay it
back morally or ethically
but has nothing to do with the other
person's Behavior it has everything to
do with the deal that was made
they took out a loan without your
knowledge and without you promising to
pay it
therefore you do not owe it
you did not handshake you did not
verbally you did not certainly not on
paper and certainly legally did not sign
for so you're not legally ethically or
morally obligated to pay this loan
period it has nothing to do with being
estranged it has nothing to do with it
it makes it weirder it has nothing to do
with the other person's Financial
misbehavior and bankruptcies that makes
it weirder but none of that is your
fault and does not change your moral
obligation one way or the other your
moral obligation is based on your
promise that was never made by you and
so you don't have a moral ethical or
legal obligation now
if you want to be generous for some
reason or another
then we can talk about it
but it's not an obligation I I like that
you said that here's where I'm
struggling with this let's say you did
Melissa let's say you did take this
money out and you shook hands hey Mom I
need some more money for room and board
and books have gotten more expensive and
your mom said great I'm going to take
out this loan this Parent PLUS Loan and
you can just pay it back even though you
don't qualify to take out your own loan
then you then you would pay it and she
ends up making very poor financial
decisions has multiple bankruptcies
doesn't matter that's right so this
external behavior is not I'm not going
to let that affect my moral cause here
um I'm with you David the reason I took
pause here is I'm thinking in my
situation if I have a parent who's
struggling
they got me through college that I'm
just torn on it I was torn on I would
probably try to figure out a way to pay
it back it would just be generosity
though it's not an obligation and in my
mind too it would be a
what should how does it affect your
particular life okay you have two
million dollars in checking
well write a check and pay it off right
yeah it's like buying a biscuit right
okay you have no money and you're just
now coming out of baby step three just
starting you're 26 years old and your
mom's killed you made 75 000 a year and
you know her voice in your head that you
haven't even heard in a long time in
person is guilt-tripping you uh then no
that's just uh psychological backflips
there you go you're just doing you're
just doing gymnastics in your own brain
there like somehow it's going to make
her okay somehow it's going to make your
relationship okay that you wave This
Magic Money wand over it and
everything's going to be okay nope not
going to happen uh and so this does come
down to two things number one is are you
obligated the answer is no number two do
you want to be generous and for me if I
were in your shoes that would be
that it's not a big deal that you can
that twenty thousand dollars you're
you're a doc and you make four hundred
thousand a year now I don't know
whatever scenario we don't have our
income or her net worth here
um but uh you know I kind of smell
in the verbiage that this is a 26 year
old
making less than a hundred thousand
dollars a year and doesn't have any
money well and to add on to that this
feels like in in Dave we don't talk
about this enough we probably should the
number of parents who mortgage their
souls for the kids to go to school and
they Circle back 10 15 years later
asking kids where's my I need that money
or without without having a deal with we
never had a deal we I got you through
college now I'm looking at my retirement
hey I put twenty thousand dollars on the
line when are you gonna pay me back and
that's the same idiot though that that
um it's common that says you owe me
because I changed your diaper oh yeah
you know that's the same art you know I
fed you when you were three shut up you
signed up for that that's right you know
that's not that's just bull right there
so uh sorry Mom that's how this works
um you know but the uh um yeah so a lot
a lot of stuff going on here but but I
think I don't want to be the
psychologist here you're that you're
that's your job but in my mind it sounds
like
um
you probably intellectually Raj but some
part of your little girl's self Melissa
wants it to be that the script is
Rewritten if you write a twenty thousand
dollar check that suddenly Mom's okay
and your relationship with Mom's okay
and that's not gonna happen and it's not
ever going to be the same thing that
house burned yes and now you got to
build something new and if part of you
building something new is I'm gonna go
back to everybody who played a role in
my life and I'm going to be generous to
them that's cool that can be a part of
your house that you're building for you
into the future that's not going to save
Mom it's not got anything to do it's not
going to save them that's right this has
got to do with you that's right yeah but
it's not a moral ethical Christian
obligation that you pay someone else's
debt
that's right it's that simple and that's
what a parent plus loan is and then I
think it is good one more time let's
Circle back for the sake of people
listening because we have a student loan
crisis that is of Epic Proportions moms
and dads do not take out student loans
of any kind and do not take out a Parent
PLUS Loan and then saddle your kid with
it when they're 30 Suddenly at
Thanksgiving dinner
okay that's relationship Russian
Roulette number one number two it's
morally ethically wrong number three
it's financially stupid okay don't do
that
and so uh you know this idea that
you know the send the kid to college at
any cost including the cost of all our
futures mine and yours we're going to
all go deeply in debt so you can get a
degree in left-handed puppetry and so
this has got to stop it will work out
for me down the road like I'm I'm I'm
cashing out some of my retirement so
that you can make it okay for all of us
yeah you can take care of me because
you'll be the the one that gets an NFL
contract it just doesn't work that way
no it doesn't work that way you can buy
Mom a house later no that's not how it
works darling yeah that can get real
real tough Uh Kevin Hart has a great bit
about that about it's not a bid it's
very serious about hey guys first
royalty check for I think it's 250 000
bucks and he said in his head it was oh
fantastic and I can get Mom a car I can
get Mom a house I can get brother a
house I can go ahead and get myself take
and then after the management management
took their cut and after the agent took
their cut and after Sam took their cut
it was not nearly the amount of money
right so we get to counting and playing
Monopoly in our head with this imaginary
stuff it's going to come down the road
and it just doesn't work out this
families get confused I was with a
friend of mine this weekend that's um
uh his um his uh
one of his parents passed away and he's
trying to protect the mom
because he said now that that dad's gone
uh all these uh
people and he named the ethnicity
okay we'll be coming around mom and
we've got to protect mom from these
people you know and it's family within
that particular culture and he said I
got to protect my mom from that and uh
because they're going to come gosh you
know Dad's Gone they're gonna smell
there's there's money and it must be
this coming the sharks are circling you
know yeah the money and it must be there
because the old man's gone now we can
get the old lady she's a soft touch we
can get the money out of her yikes yeah
wow that's the thing man it's a thing
you people in your families
mine's perfect Dave
hey you know the saying around Ramsey if
you think there's not crazy in your
family then it's you
this is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
hey it's John deloney co-host of the
Ramsey show did you know over 18
[Music]
to find a station near you go to
ramseysolutions.com show
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
live from the headquarters of Ramsay
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studios it's the
Ramsay show we're dead as dumb cash is
king and the paid off Home Mortgage has
taken the place of the BMW as the status
symbol of choice we help people build
wealth do work that they love to create
actual amazing relationships Dr John
deloney Ramsey personality number one
best-selling author host of the Dr John
deloney show is my co-host today thank
you for joining us America Jessica
starts with us this hour she's in
Indianapolis hi Jessica how are you
hey I'm all right Dave how are you
better than I deserve what's up
good hey um first off just want to say
how much I appreciate y'all they say
surround yourself with people you want
to be most liked in life and uh so I
listen to a lot of you and your team so
thank you thank you
um yeah I just wanted to I'll kind of
jump into it um a little background I am
um
dealing with some health issues I deal
with Lyme disease and then a lot of
issues that have kind of come off of
that so I've been unemployed for about
seven years
um due to this and my husband left in um
early of 2021 and we officially had a
divorce finalized this past spring
um I'm been living off of some
settlement money but it is not lasting
long I have to cover my own medical
expenses and different you know my own
personal things I I live with family so
I don't have
um the cost of like a rent or utilities
but everything else is on me
um and I guess I'm just I know the Bible
talks about you know
being prudent and planning ahead and so
I'm looking at my situation and
um being unable to work but without an
income not really sure where I'm going
to end up here in a few months what I'm
going to do about this situation and
so I guess I'm just looking for some
counsel on
um
what maybe I can be doing with what I
have left or what can I be doing to
prepare because I definitely don't want
to be
um you know when he walked out I was
left with this vulnerable feeling I've
never felt in my life of what do I do
about my money and I never want to feel
that way again so my hope is to get back
to working again but in until then what
can I be doing to prepare myself for
financial stability
when I get there how old are you
uh 33. wow who are you living with
um parents at the moment at the moment
how long will that last
oh as long as it needs to it's
the what's the barrier between you and
getting a job going back to work
is it cognitive you get tired is it
movement what is it yeah you know it's
it's
being able to do physical it's very much
cognitive I actually love the Ken
Coleman show and he inspired me a little
while back that when my husband left I
actually went ahead and got a
certification myself to be a coach but
I've not been able to follow through
with it just because uh not I mean
everything else with life my body's just
taken an even harder hit over the past
year and a half
um so my my body has not allowed me to
do anything with that but I have it in
hopes that I will get to use it
um coaching can become very hard because
you're taking on you're carrying two
people stuff
or you're sitting in two people's mess
years and whoever you're sitting with
um my recommendation right now would
probably be
getting some teeny tiny little wins
what does it look like to get
um
seven hours a week at a thing
and practicing how you feel and being
very intentional right this has been
going on seven years and so at some
point you you balance whatever pain
you're in whatever cognitive brain fog
you've got whatever Lyme's disease
Downstream stuff you got going on with
this identity that I can't do anything
and that I'm use I'm completely
dependent on other people and that that
dependence is terrifying once you
realize oh nobody's coming for me he
left
right and so seeing yourself make some
teeny tiny progress find out what your
limits truly are because it's been seven
years right
you've probably tried every remedy in
the world for Lyme because it's just a
mess that can be a quagmire right
yeah
why are you not been declared
permanently disabled and aren't
receiving SSI well that's the other yeah
why would you yeah Social Security
benefits yeah so I'm actually actually
in the process of that and that's a
whole thing at this point I'm waiting
it's been seven years why are you just
now in doing that
because when I looked in the past I got
bad information
it was my understanding that without a
diagnosis I couldn't apply for it I mean
I had a guy I had a guy on the team that
got Lyme disease and he's collecting on
our Disability Policy still and that was
a decade plus ago and he's also
collecting SSI
yeah I was told
um I don't remember who it was but in
the past when I looked into it that
without a diagnosis I wasn't able to
collect and I just received the
diagnosis this year oh the Lyme disease
diagnosis was now after six years
yeah I've been to doctors like
continually so I I just had someone
about a year ago say have you been
tested for this and I was like No And so
there it is that came later then that
also opens up some treatment options
that you didn't have prior to
yeah we the thing is
um that in trading for or that going so
long without it being identified you
start developing a lot of other issues
and so now there's kind of a big because
what he had or I don't I don't know what
else you've had something wise but I'm
no doc but I just watched him he's my
friend he worked here was extreme
fatigue
oh yes he thought he had Mono yeah you
know he thought he had a a neurological
disorder which Lyme disease kind of is
but
um yeah but I mean wow okay so listen
either you get functioning or you go get
SSI
so I'm I'm actually in the middle of
trying to get SSI but they told me I'm
I'm waiting I've got a 12 to 15 month
wait just to get my hearing date
um because I'm working with a disability
attorney to try and get help with that
and I've been denied two or three times
now it's going to I will deny you and
deny you and deny you and deny you
that's their game well that was prior to
the lung disease diagnosis though no no
no that's now you've been denied after
the diagnosis
yeah and they're telling me I likely
will not win my case because the time
frame I missed it by a month of the five
year mark I had to apply
[Music]
all right so
um because my family can't carry me they
can put a roof on my head listen I have
a friend who continued to keep showing
up and keep showing up and keep showing
up with SSI and they kept denying kept
denying kept denying kept denying and
then just had a successful outcome years
so don't give up that don't give up that
yeah and in the meantime then I would go
with John and let's say look for some
small wins look for some things you can
do without lifting a car
um and um I mean we just had a really
thorough cognitive conversation with you
here for you know five ten minutes so
that no that means I know you can do
that right and uh maybe coaching's not
it right now no but I'm just saying
there's a lot of stuff you can do these
days uh with the from home yeah maybe
you're an advocate for people that have
got stuff like that I don't know uh but
anyway there's some employment for you
that you can do with the limitations but
you just got to search it out and figure
it out probably self-employed of some
kind
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
if you're looking for ways to update
your home without blowing the budget
I've got it for years I've been telling
you about our friends at blinds.com
blinds.com makes it simple to shop top
quality blinds Shades and interior
shutters from home with easy online
ordering and free shipping with
blinds.com there's no need to renovate
your entire home just change out what's
on your windows with upscale choices
like faux wood blinds cellular and
roller Shades or even outdoor Shades
plus blinds.com guarantees the perfect
fit whether you do it yourself or you
have them measure and install everything
for you shop their latest looks and see
how much you can save at blinds.com
today the easy and affordable way to
make your home more beautiful is
blinds.com
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
Dr John deloney Ramsey personality is my
co-host today thank you for joining us
America we're glad you're here open
phones at triple eight eight two five
five two two five we talk about a lot of
things that you do to be successful with
money around here let me tell you one of
them that will break the break the back
of the whole thing for you
generosity
we probably don't spend enough time
talking about the power of generosity to
transform your life
the generous person's life
and uh it does every year around this
time heading up to Christmas we always
do a uh an annual giving show where we
take calls for three hours with your
giving and receiving stories stories
that blow people's minds with generosity
where you've received or you've given we
want to hear your actual story from your
actual mouth on the show email us at ask
ramseysolutions.com the email address is
ask
ramsesolutions.com December the 14th
we're going to be sharing these our
giving show will be that day and just
put in the in the subject line of your
email giving and the team will get back
to you and schedule you to be a caller
we don't tell you what to say but we set
up the time for you to call
uh and be a part of the giving show
again the email is ask at
ramsesolutions.com giving in the subject
line Chris is with us in Odessa Texas hi
Chris welcome to the Ramsay show
well thank you for having me I uh I
can't believe I can't believe I got
through well we're glad you did how can
we help
well I got a question for you I'm
looking for some advice
um to make it short and sweet
um
I'm wondering do I stay with a
physically comfortable job that barely
pays the bills or do I go back to
something that I left because it was
becoming physically well physically
painful
um for double the salary
uh before I answer that question or we
answer the question why have you boxed
yourself into either no money and it's
soft and cushy or I can't physically do
the work but it makes a lot of money
yeah how about C none of the above
[Laughter]
well
um
unfortunately because I
I
those are the you know the things I know
the best
ah okay and so uh what are you making at
the cushy job that's not physically
demanding
uh okay at the cushy job is not
physically demanding uh we're at uh just
under 60 a year and the other one's 120.
uh well close it's uh it's 194. okay and
uh Odessa so what oil field
yes sir okay how old are you
I'm 58 and therein lies part of the
problem you know because uh
um I'm kind of uh kind of a dinosaur
yeah yeah in in the eyes of employers
now
[Music]
okay have you is there a possibility to
move on to
get some credentialing so you can go be
a supervisor at some of these sites
or go test go test the water and go test
the the
um the gas extractions I mean there's
there's different ways to be involved in
this field and make killer money you
just gotta have to go back and get some
certifications that's not a roughneck
yeah it's not turning wrenches yeah is
that possible yeah
um
I I guess it would be uh I got a feeling
you have knowledge about that stuff from
just practical Hands-On Common Sense
knowledge
yes sir yes sir I do I do and I've been
a mechanic for 30 years before this so
yeah you can smell this stuff long
before the analysts figure it out
so yeah yes yeah and so what if you were
also an analyst is what John is saying
or whatever you're a certified dot dot
dot fill it in that you kind of used to
roll your eyes at but they make good
money and they also utilize your
knowledge and experience of the oil
field in your knowledge and experience
put with a little bit of Education in
that area might make you very valuable
and unusual kind of a unicorn there's a
reason why they all their trucks are
nicer than than the young guys can I ask
you a personal question Chris
go ahead you got in trouble with the law
before
no no never okay I sent some hesitation
what is it that is keeping you from
taking a leadership position or moving
in towards towards that role why do you
see yourself at 60 years old it's just a
guy that turns wrenches
well I I love doing it I'm very good at
it and part of the reason I'm in the oil
field for the last couple of years is
because that's what I did for uh a long
time and when covet came and everything
was shut down
um you know the dealership I was working
at
um you know you've got just got too
tight and they belong to me as long as
they could but uh you know the first
ones to go or the overpaid you know
managers and service managers and uh the
new hires and unfortunately I was one of
the overpaid service managers at the
time
uh I bet with your experience you
weren't overpaid a penny I bet you made
them a money hand over fist because
you're really good at what you do man
you're one of those guys like Dave said
you can smell it like you you can feel
an engine like a heart surgeon can feel
inside of somebody's chest cavity you're
really good at it right sure okay so
here's what I want here's what I want
all right
um
what John and are both poking around on
and I'll just say it out loud as there
the uh the options you presented
and the words you use to present them
um
indicated that I that your confidence in
you is lower than our confidence in you
and we've just talked to you for a few
minutes we think that you are much more
valuable than you think you are
yeah that's uh
that that is part of it yeah because if
you believed by God I'm valuable you'd
go take three classes at the community
college put a little certification after
your name and walk in like a stud in the
middle of this next thing and own it
you'd buy yourself a second dually to
get out to your your sights with and you
test the water and you tell those
knucklehead young kids out there
whatever it is exactly I don't care
whatever area that you've got knowledge
in that you could step back and use your
mind in instead of your back
uh because you've got the experience the
stored in your mind and that experience
is not duplicatable in a 24 year old
right college graduate
it's just not or my buddies that left
college and just went straight to the
work field right I mean do oil field
either one if they're 30 you know you
dude you just you know there is a value
to The Human Experience there's a value
to you've been standing there when this
happened uh and you can't replace that
that has that's quite the opposite of
I'm not employable because I'm 58
instead you're quite employable because
you're 58 that's right if you turn the
narrative a little bit and twist it on
its head to go a different direction so
that's the way I'm going to think about
this so uh I'm going with C of your
options none of the above and I'm going
to figure out a way around the edges of
this where I get to do something that's
not back breaking but that I get to plug
into a business that I know a lot about
an industry that I know a lot about but
plug into it from a different way than I
ever dreamed of before it's as if you
were 18 years old and you got a fresh
start with a clean white board and you
can pick out anything you wanted to do
now go do that that's right uh man I
really think you should and I think you
can uh more than you did at the start of
this call so I'm going to plug into Ken
Coleman's stuff he's one of our Ramsay
personalities here you may want to talk
to him on the Ken Coleman show or when
he's on here one of these days in the
meantime I'm going to send you a copy of
his book paycheck to purpose and I'm
always also going to sign you up for his
assessment I want you to take that it's
all free we're going to give it to you
free because we believe in you and we
think you can go do some stuff now when
you turn this around and you're making a
hundred twenty thousand hundred thirty
thousand doing something else that is
doing the stuff we're talking about we'd
love to hear back from you that
our belief in you was well founded
that's right and I I've I mean this
happened with my buddies who were police
officers my buddies who were wrench
Turners my buddy you know I'm from that
area who were out
um you know uh turning wrenches in the
oil field
we are the Roughnecks we are the guys
that get it done leadership is over
there and then I've got friends who are
in leadership who are like I don't sweep
the floors that's for those folks we
gotta get over that man and at some
point I think you're a gift if you can
take your wisdom and knowledge and
transfer it to the leadership you can be
the leader that you never ever had what
a gift right and vice versa you can be a
leader that goes and picks up a broom
and you do whatever it takes to help
everybody be successful first church I
went into I went into the fellowship
hall there's an old man setting up
chairs and I'm like hey who's that
senior passenger Pastor that's
leadership right there this is the
Ramsay show
[Music]
I say it all the time if you're a
business owner and you don't know your
numbers you don't know your business and
when markets are shifting it's even more
important you've got to know where you
stand so you make your next move the
right move and you don't have to be in
the dark here over 31 000 businesses
including my team at Ramsey know their
numbers because they use netsuite by
Oracle the number one Cloud Financial
system netsuite gives you visibility and
control of your financials planning
budgeting and inventory so you can
manage risk get reliable forecasts and
improve margins having everything in one
place has saved my team hours each week
since we made the switch to netsuite
netsuite is a game changer so head on
over to netsuite.com Ramsey to get a
product tour today that's netsuite.com
Ramsay
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
Ramsey personality number one
best-selling author is my co-host today
in the lobby of Ramsey Solutions I'm the
debt free stage Kevin and Elizabeth are
with us welcome guys how are you
where do you guys live Irvine California
California awesome welcome to Nashville
and how much data have you paid off
we paid off
132 256 dollars excellent how long did
that take two years six months two years
and six months and uh your range of
income during that two years and six
months we started at 38 000 and ended at
121 and 842 whoa okay very cool what do
y'all do for a living
um well I used to be a Behavioral
Analyst and now I'm a homemaker okay and
uh I hang wallpaper for the family
company okay so how'd you go from 38 to
122 with that gyration well Dave
um
I know it's not a wallpaper yeah rich
people or some they're more afraid of
wallpaper than they are leaves
I'm very afraid of wallpaper leaves will
not kill you wallpaper will break up a
marriage I've heard many horror stories
yeah
wow so you that really your your
business is thriving it's right amounts
too yeah I in the beginning it was like
an apprenticeship with my dad and I just
started learning more and more and I he
trusted me with bigger jobs and more
jobs and just grew from there awesome
what kind of debt was the 132 000. uh we
had Disney annual passes we had uh car
loans credit cards student loans
everything yeah
Disney he leads with Disney annual
passes yeah that's the lead on credit
you owed money on them
you borrowed on your Disney annual
passes well we were college students at
the time so oh that even makes it that's
even worse you didn't even have kids
y'all were going for you
oh no
I always wondered if y'all were for real
like you are they're out there they're
out there now we've met a real one in
the wild
um all right so uh okay how long y'all
been married
um it's going to be four years so a
couple years into marriage you looked up
and said uh the way we're doing this is
not working tell us your story what
happened
well uh when we first got married we
were looking for a place you know we're
looking for somewhere to live and we
were looking to get a mortgage and
when the loan officer told us you know
you have
over a hundred thousand dollars in debt
and your income is thirty eight thousand
dollars what are you you're not what do
you think is going to happen you're not
going to get a house so so when he quit
laughing yeah that was embarrassing you
were shamed I'm shamed out of the
mortgage guy's office yeah then you did
what
well I had heard your like a commercial
for your show uh in like my dad's truck
when we're on our way to work and I
checked it out one day and I pitched the
idea to her and she was against it and I
was for it and he's crazy I'm not gonna
do that
you're not gonna control my money and
no after that conversation with the
financial
um
advisor we were like okay we we have to
grow up and you know get on a plan and
why not this one yep yep so you plugged
into our stuff how how did you get how'd
you get lined up with ours honestly we
just listened to the podcast we listened
to the radio show and I got your
audiobook I've listened to apply like
six times and every time I feel like I'm
getting off track I just listen to it
again okay all right let me suck to it
what what brought you around to this
Elizabeth that Shocker from the mortgage
guy or
um yeah it was the the shock of like
what do you mean like I'm working so
much why why don't I have money to do
things and um like after hearing that it
was it was eyeball opening and you know
we we really had to sit down and um in
order like in order for us to work in in
a marriage I really thought okay we need
to both get on a plan yeah and I mean we
started and I was like okay let's give
it a try and that try ended up like
helping us all together two years or six
months later yep you're free yes
what is that what does that feel like
because it sounds like you've never seen
this done before like you maybe you
didn't come from families that that
traded money this way
how does this feel because this is all
new yeah it feels um surreal I mean
people I mean even in our own family
look at us kind of crazy of like how are
you doing this what is this going to get
to you but
um it it has helped us so much in our
marriage and our in our journey of
becoming parents
um with our first pregnancy
um we like our son
um we found out he had like a heart
condition and
um we had to really pick a plan to in
order to help them out as he was going
to be born and that like that called
into being um like relocated to
Pennsylvania
um and you know through it all
um we were blessed with seven weeks with
him and by his bedside and the fact that
we didn't have to worry about money
and we could focus on him
like that has helped me like even after
losing him
what an amazing way to you did the work
up front so that you so that you had the
opportunity to honor that beautiful
little boy as much as Paul right yes
yeah um what an amazing Testament you
had the honor and privilege of just
getting to to be with him mourn and and
hold your son right and then shortly
after we we lost our son we found out we
were having another son and you know
with all those things that we can't
control in our lives
um we are truly blessed that you know
um we are able to control our money now
and that we're able to be in a sense
like stress-free from that so that we
can focus on our family and each other
and you know the things that we want to
do in our lives yeah and number two is
here and healthy yep yes yes
that's amazing guys wow stork mode is so
important when you say to stop and
stockpile cash I mean that was just
life-changing for us
well I mean you're yeah you
I can't I can't breathe just hearing the
story well you know and and if you had
to worry about
um money and all the other stuff that
would just be more than you could Bear
yeah and I mean we were blessed with
like a community and church our church
really supported us through everything
and
um
like having those skills of managing our
money like their help with their
contributions like it was allocated in
right the correct places
yeah you got a little exclamation point
on your debt free huh
say the least to say the least couple of
them yeah wow amazing what an incredible
reminder that no matter who we are how
much we plan things out life's coming
for us right yeah and it's going to
surprise us in good ways and it's going
to surprise us surprise us with
devastating ways and if you've done the
work to take control of your at least
provide yourself a foundation
financially you're ready to with Come
What May right yep what a blessing y'all
are what do you tell people the key to
getting out of debt is
honestly the it's following the steps
how you lay them out there's no
deviating from the plan you gotta follow
the steps
and you just got to stick to them long
term it's like it's hard sometimes you
get distracted and you want to you you
want to do other things you want to go
out with your friends but just like
really sticking to it and keeping your
head down and just just keep going yeah
just following the steps to the T yeah
you had every excuse in the world with
the with the Heartbreak and the process
you've been through to go off the rails
and to go do something crazy with money
and medicate you know the the sorrow and
the grief with it and you chose not to
you chose to just stay on a plan which
is do nothing except pile up cash until
baby comes and then you get to do it
again do nothing but pile up yeah no
baby come and uh and then the net result
is today 132 thousand dollars gone in
two years since six months and a lot of
Life lived during that time yeah yep and
a lot of wallpaper taken down yep
there's a lot of wallpaper
that's a lot wallpaper hey we've got The
Total Money Makeover book for you the
baby steps millionaires book for you and
a one-year membership to Financial Peace
University for you that's the live and
give bundle enjoy it or give it whatever
you want to do Kevin and Elizabeth and
Luke from Irvine and your son's name
that's in heaven Hudson oh Hudson Hudson
Hudson awesome
132 000 paid off in two years and six
months making 38 to 122. count it down
let's hear a debt-free scream three two
one we're set free yeah
[Applause]
and Luke has on a Mickey shirt note
Michelle no this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
Dr John deloney Ramsey personality is my
co-host today host of the Dr John
deloney show author of the number one
best-selling book own your past change
your future well we're in the holiday
season where our brains are focused on
buying presents decorating our homes and
all the Christmas and New Year's
celebrations all of a sudden it's
January and you feel like you're behind
on everything
a little bit of a financial hangover
doesn't have to be that way
when you start the new year you can
start strong
you can start by joining us for the
Building Wealth live event here in
Nashville on January the 12th this one
night event will help you kick 2023
help you start it off feeling confident
about your money even in this weird
crazy economy George Campbell Rachel
Cruz Ken Coleman Dr John deloney to my
right and I will be there we're going to
walk you through a plan to get on track
and build wealth yes right now it is
still possible
are Building Wealth and Live Events have
been a huge hit they've been sellouts
all this year and we just wrapped out
they wrapped up the sold out fall season
it was awesome our January event will be
here in about 20 seconds and it'll be at
the Ramsey headquarters right here and
then we're headed to Indianapolis Austin
Salt Lake City and Anaheim with dates in
the spring we're telling you if you need
some motivation this is the thing passes
for all of these start at just 39 head
over to ramsesolutions.com
events Building Wealth live in Nashville
don't miss it
ramseysolutions.com
events Phoenix is on the line and uh
that's Ed calling hi Ed what's up
hello Dave thanks for taking my call
sure how can we help
well I you know I'm just uh you know in
this turmoil that we're in the middle of
the with the markets and everything I've
I've been retired for a few years
I had a divorce late in life
and uh which which allowed me to be uh
debt free but it was very painful sure
um uh but uh you know I've got I've got
some pretty good money in the bank a
little over a million bucks and maybe
not today the Market's down a little bit
but uh but I wake up every day looking
at the markets and and pondering about
what I should be doing and and I just
didn't know if you guys thought you know
I've got Social Security's coming up
pretty soon and I've got a retirement
package that that'll give me some money
um if you thought I should uh you know
purchase a house how old are you
uh 65. okay and your retirement package
consists of what
uh about 40 000 a year okay why would
you not purchase a house
why would I not
well uh well first of all most of the
money's tied up in 401ks and and that
kind of stuff and so if I take that
money out of that you know 200 000 off
for a down payment
um or even hey try to pay cash for it uh
you know I'm gonna pay a whole lot of
tax on that that deal
and my rent is so what else are you
going to do with money
there's keep it in work keep it keep it
where it's at and let it uh go up and
down and the next 20 years rent goes up
every year
yeah
this is the thought behind it and
and here in the in the in the Arizona
Market the you know housing prices have
just gone up through the roof s
um they're coming down a little bit now
but they've been
amazingly High yeah they're not they're
not gonna come down much more
um I don't think uh I think there's just
a market slowed down but I'm not seeing
prices drop there were some unrealistic
prices that are now getting realistic
but
um but there's not a there's not like a
devaluation of real estate so here's the
thing if you live 20 more years you're
going to wish you own real estate
okay I plan on living 20 years yeah I
mean think about 20 years ago
that you had purchased in 2002 so yeah
and I'm going to pay cash for whatever I
buy no down payment I'm gonna pay cash
for it you've got the money
here's what I want you to do
this is going to be a spiritual practice
for you
I want you to stop getting up and
staring at the markets all day every day
strapping yourself into this roller
coaster going up and down these are in
Floral ones there's no business there's
no reason to torture yourself this way
man you're making yourself nuts yeah I'd
leave it I'd leave the leave the
newspaper leave the website alone it's
not it's not a newspaper anymore I'm
sorry
but the uh they're not pamphlets but um
hop out of the covered wagon U.S
newspaper USA Today yeah so pamphlet um
just stopped you're making you're
torturing yourself buy a house man best
small reasonable house for us for one
value three or four hundred thousand
dollar house or condo and that way you
own it you have no payments it's not
going up in rent you stabilized that
part of your life you're going to get a
sense of peace and a sense of calm that
being uh at someone else's beck and call
as a renter does not give you
um it is a good use for some of your
million dollars uh oh and by the way
forty thousand will go a long way
towards being able to live on it without
touching the other money plus so
security don't yeah plus plus Social
Security but if you don't have a
mortgage payment of any kind or rent
payment uh you know pretty good life on
that and if you want to use some of that
other money to enjoy that's fine you got
you're going to be fine you're gonna be
fine so let's say you spend 400 000 and
you don't touch the 600 000 it'll be a
million two in seven years
if you've got it in mutual funds
and then it'll be 2.4 million in seven
more years
if you don't touch it
or if you do touch it and take a little
out of it it'll still be 2 million
and while we're here hassling you
find something that you can do locally
whether that's getting a job that works
part-time or you can be one of those
super awesome guys at Home Depot that
helps Knuckleheads like me try to figure
out what to do or
um serve at a restaurant do something
that you've got to get up and go do
every day it's going to get you off the
computer and get you off the television
screen and you can make a little money
on the side or make some good money but
go do something
Sarah's in Minneapolis hi Sarah welcome
to the Ramsey Show
hi guys thanks for taking my call sure
um question about opening um like a
little bit of a side business
um my sister and I actually came up with
an idea we wanted to do
together
um I know it's not advised to go into
business
with like a partnership necessarily
um but just wondering how do we go about
then kind of
play area
in our town it would be like a side gate
we both work
um full time so who's going to run it
while you're at work
um
we have it open in like the weekend
hours and a few like days here there
when we have days off over the holidays
we'd hopefully have someone also like
bath it
um if we're not available
for two moms who are desperate to have a
place to send their kids
that is not a fully formed business idea
yet
okay
yeah you're not open okay you're just
going to be open when like it's
convenient for you and your kids want to
play okay this is not going to be you're
gonna go broke I mean you're gonna spend
50 000 bucks building this thing and
it's going to take you 50 000 years to
break even on it if you don't think this
through a little bit further you're not
got enough customers enough hours yet in
your mind for this too because I mean
you're gonna have to rent a spot and or
where were you going to put it like in a
mall or what
yeah yep we're hoping that there's an
area in our town or a mall that isn't
being utilized so we're hoping to have
some space in there that's not the
utilize like store friends
we've done other like play areas and
just kind of fell in love with the idea
um I've got I've got I've got a
six-year-old the idea sounds great to me
that I have a place that I know is
always open that I could take her
but I in my life
um it's either going to be a routine
like we're going to go there every day
or every other day or it's gonna be
man the internet went out the the movie
we're gonna go see is sold out or
something we can't make it and so we're
just gonna show up and right now y'all
are like well you know every other
weekend and a couple of days here and
there you need to sit down and come up
with an actual business plan of what
this would look like yeah how are you
going to be open normal hours that
people can bring their kids on a regular
basis yeah because you don't there's all
kinds of these uh franchises now out
there competing with you for play space
that have every bouncy thing in the
world in it um rope thing in the world I
mean I've been in them with the
grandkids I don't even know what they're
called but
um yeah you're competing with those and
you're gonna have to have a real
business plan and then either you work
for your sister or she works for you and
the other one put it in you own it or
she owns it we don't need to be partners
that's a good recipe for I don't want to
be in this in six months and then we've
got a real problem
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
all of our shows with the Ramsay Network
app on your smartphone it's the only
place to listen to the entire back
catalog of episodes download the Ramsay
Network app in your favorite app store
today
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsay
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving in storage Studios it's the
Ramsay show where that is dumb cash is
king and the paid off Home Mortgage has
taken the place of the BMW as the status
symbol of choice we help people build
wealth do work they love and create
actual amazing relationships Dr John
deloney Ramsey personality is my co-host
today he's the host of the Dr John
deloney show where he talks about mental
Wellness boundaries relationships
everything in the world having to do
with you and your family and your life
you can call there anytime and you can
call here today the phone number is
Triple Eight
825-5225
Trina is in Springfield Illinois to
start this hour hi Trina how are you I'm
doing good how about you better than I
deserve what's up
so I have a question I have 363
000 in debt and I'm trying to figure out
if I need to sell my car in the mix of
that or if I'm okay with the income that
I make
what kind of debt is 363 000.
327 000 is the house 29 000 is the car
and 7 500 is student loans what do you
make
I make 133 000 a year okay excellent
you're single
I am okay three children though so
technically not entirely single okay
well um you know what we would teach you
to do is obviously to uh save a thousand
dollars is baby step one you have any
money in savings not counting retirement
I have
retirement I have 150 four thousand
in what just a savings account
okay write a check today and pay off
your car and your student loans
really really
okay
if you didn't if you didn't have debt on
your car if you didn't have debt on your
car and you had 70 000 in savings would
you go borrow on your car to put 30 in
savings
no same thing
what kind of car do you have
it's an it's Alexis good yeah 29 000. 29
000 car when you're making 133 is not
out of line especially when you write a
check and you pay for it so we're gonna
do that today now once you're debt free
it sounds like to me that you've got
uh
what 60 000 bucks left over okay seventy
thousand bucks left over right all right
um and so we have a series of things we
call the baby steps which is your proper
the fastest right way to walk through
and build wealth from where you are
today okay number one is an emergency
fund of uh a thousand dollars two is
your debt free but the house we just did
that now we got seventy thousand dollars
left over three is an emergency fund a
fully funded emergency fund of three to
six months of expenses you have more
than that now so we're gonna earmark
some of the seventy thousand for three
to six months of expenses so in your
world that's probably Thirty forty
thousand bucks something like that
whatever you want something like that
I'm gonna set that aside don't touch it
in a separate money market account it
does nothing but just sit there in case
it rains it's your umbrella
okay that's always forced when the
storms come okay then the rest of it
we're going to use to finish up here and
or to move through the rest of it uh
baby step fours would be putting 15 of
your income away in retirement are you
already putting money in retirement
um I was until last month I stopped
because I was like I need to really pay
off my debt that I have before I go
because I was putting about 600 aside
yeah okay so I want you to now put 15 of
your income into retirement do you have
a 401k at work
I do I have a couple 401ks
you work two jobs
I used to I used to so you can't add to
something unless you're there so I want
you putting 15 of your income away in a
401K Roth with a match and or a regular
Roth both in good mutual funds a total
of 15 of 133 and so we're talking about
about 20 grand
a year which is almost two thousand
dollars a month
but you don't have any payments anymore
now except your house okay exactly now
and we've got
then that moves us to baby step five I'm
walking you right up the plan with the
money that you've got and the income
that you have and then maybe step five
is kids college I'm probably taking some
of that money that's left over after we
funded the emergency fund and paid off
the car in the student loan and I'm
gonna sit down with a smartvester pro
and start my kids college funds with
that money
okay sounds like you got about 10 grand
each to put in towards that by the time
the Smoke Clears on all this
okay and that gets that going and then
baby step six is now when you find other
money in your budget or in your life you
throw it at the mortgage and once you
begin to pay the mortgage off early
probably going to take you six or seven
years ten years to knock that out
okay while you're putting 15 away while
you're funding your kids college fund
while you're never borrowing money again
all of that you have done so good well
done
well thanks it was kind of I feel guilty
owning this car because I've always
driven junkers because I'm kind of a
cheap person so it's nice to hear that
I'm actually okay to own that car yeah
our rule of thumb is don't have things
with motors and wheels
um that added up together equal more
than half your annual income
okay and if they do you got too much
tied up in things
that go down in value
okay so I wouldn't do that but in your
case you got 30 grand tied up you make
133 so what do you do for a living thank
you I I'm working in the medical field
okay all right how long have you been
single
um actually just recently
so kind of kind of makes me stop to
reevaluate my entire life so yeah
painful I'm sorry very very painful not
something that's fun to go through yeah
the good news is you walk out of it with
a great career and a pile of cash
obviously that allows you to clean up
and I'm kind of dusting out the corners
here while we're talking
yeah I definitely wanted
if they're just in German
uh how much is your whole is your house
worth
uh 436
that's a lot of house in Waco is that
the house you want to stay in for for
the foreseeable future
no I really don't even like the house I
bought it because that's what my husband
wanted was this the home you'll shared
before the divorce
correct although it is my home I did buy
it before we were married ah okay okay
and maybe that's that's something to
think about if you end up wanting to
downsize your home when was the divorce
okay sit there a little bit Yeah follow
Dave don't do anything right now sit
there and breathe a little bit uh and
you know six months six months from now
if you're your mind clears from the rage
and the grief
you'll make you might make a different
decision I'm not saying you don't need
to move I'm saying I wouldn't make a
decision while I'm
um going through one of life's most
horrible things
yeah yeah Center off you gotta there's
some grief involved in this and you're
all of us our brains are a little bit
more clouded when we're grieving raging
whatever it is we do after we go through
something like this but the moves I gave
you I would make those anyway and I
would sit on the house a little bit and
let's let it sit
um hey Hang on we're going to put you
into Financial Peace University to give
you the knowledge and give you the
confidence while you're walking this
last bit of this out and it'll show you
exactly to do what I just told you to do
as well so hang on I'm going to pay for
that for you to go through
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
deloney Ramsey personality is my co-host
today as we answer your questions about
life and about money Chad is with us in
Boston hi Chad how are you
thank you and John thank you for taking
my call today sure what's up
so I have um uh my parents are are 73
and 75 and I've just been recently
appointed power of attorney over their
finances to help them do some debt they
have about 25 000 credit card debt
um 17 on a car and a 45 000
uh personal uh business loan and 475 000
mortgage
they bring in about 5 000 a month from
pension and social security they don't
have anything in retirement and they
have a rental income from half of their
house that brings in about 2200 a month
so the minimum payments on everything
are about 7 200 a month right what they
bring in
um and I'm wondering how I can stop the
credit card accounts and
be able to stop the interest and stuff
so that we can pay them down and not
have them all accruing interest and and
fees every month and um talking to a
consolidation company uh they want you
to send them the money and then
stop paying the payments and then in 60
to 90 days they'll make a settlement
with them and you just keep sending them
the the agreed upon payment which does
to your parents and credit exactly the
same as filing a Chapter 13 bankruptcy
right and then you'll also you'll also
find that the consolidation company does
not follow through on their promises
right it's a dirty slimy business so uh
what's your parents house worth
uh I'm thinking somewhere around 800 000
are they important health
uh my mom is my mom's incapacitive and
in the hospital right now I'm sorry
yeah okay and why are you why are you
the power of attorney they just threw up
their hands and said we can't we don't
know what to do or what
my mom's always done the finances and
she's LED my dad to believe that it's
everything's okay and
um you know she's been in the in and out
of the hospital since Labor Day and and
I just got involved to try to help make
sure everything was current and on time
and you have total control of the check
now checking account now
I do they don't have access to it
anymore to screw it up any further
um they do have access to it but my
mom's incapacitated my dad's on board
with getting getting things done he's
not going to touch it
no she's not gonna touch it
no okay
because you you know you um
yeah you can outrun them continuing to
do this if they if they can't put their
fingers in it your efforts are going to
be for naught
right
no other no money at all
no money at all I my dad sees all his
retirement money to try to keep this
house afloat and
um
this how long they've been in this house
about 15 years they're in Boston as well
yes just south of Boston yeah
expensive real estate market uh
okay the easy equation
is very painful
and I sell the house and pay off all the
debts and buy a house or a condo for 400
Grand that they move into that's paid
for and now they're have uh five
thousand dollars a month to
live on and they got no payments in the
world they're not going to do that uh
you're going to get kicked out of the
family if you do that
yeah that's a longer process because
there's a lot to clean out of the house
and it's a pretty unique style house so
yeah yeah but it's gonna have to I mean
if uh we're if we're three months three
years from now and your your dad is fed
up and you've made no progress and your
mom's in heaven if that happened uh
you're selling this house
that is where we're headed
that is where we're headed but we're
probably not there today emotionally
you're probably going to try some other
things first
uh did you say 17 or 12 on the car
17 on the car and you have another car
yeah we're willing to get rid of the car
yeah we have two other vehicles one of
them one of which we can sell and make
some money to pay toward the credit
cards but good yeah pay off some of the
credit cards and sell the other car
um and then let's just list our debts
smallest to largest and pay minimum
payments on everything but the little
one but there's no uh there's no magic
pill out there that you can take you can
call the credit card companies and yell
at them as the power of attorney and
you're going to send them a copy of the
power attorney or they're not even going
to talk to you they're not allowed to
but they might you know lower the
interest rate or put some short-term
moratorium on it if you work on
aggressive payment plan to clear them
um and you know you might you bribe them
how many different cards are there
oh you're gonna you're gonna die but
it's about 12. good no that's good
because that way you can play them
against each other
right in other words I would just not
pay somebody that's not cooperative and
the one that gives me great deals I'd
knock them out fast
gotcha punish the ones that don't
cooperate
sort of like with the consolidation
companies do I do it myself yeah but
you're not gonna what they do is stop
all payments
correct which destroys Mom and Dad's
credit we don't need to do that
needlessly
um because they can actually pay the
bill you get rid of the car payment and
you get rid of some of the credit cards
off a one Fell Swoop here selling two
vehicles then you know you're Back in
Balance again we're gonna be on a tight
budget beans and rice but so be it
right now what's the business loan
I I was something that my mom took out
during coven and like when they're
handing out money to everybody 45
000.
yeah so she took out a PPP loan on a
business she didn't own
well my dad had a I had a business that
he just dissolved and sold
did he make any money on the sale
no
okay you need to dig into this loan and
see what it is and see if there's some
forgiveness uh on it it might have been
a it might be a a PPP and there may be
that he might have met the guidelines
before he sold the business to have it
forgiven
okay you need to find out what it is she
did there I don't know what she did off
top of her head and you don't either yet
but I'm gonna I'm gonna Push pause on
that puppy let it sit there a little bit
until I dig into and find out what
coveted crap they did here it's probably
a PPP and it might be forgivable
depending on what he did with his
employees and so forth there's
guidelines on the Forgiveness on those
things a vast number of people though
got stuck with these like this I was
yelling at you America not to take these
things because I knew I was going to end
up with this discussion a year and a
half two years after covet and here I
sit doing this pretty regularly now
anyway that's aside from that uh so yeah
I sell the cars two of them
um
don't need much of a car here right now
uh list your credit cards smallest to
largest begin to use them to beat up on
each other uh and and negotiate them go
I got 12. I'm the power of attorney I've
got a a mom that's ill and in and out of
the hospital I got a dad that's clueless
and so what you people are is up a creek
you're not going to get paid unless you
work with me
and be kind of sassy and smart alec with
them
okay you don't have to be completely
rude but cop an attitude and a Swagger
Go 75 Boston on them not full Boston 75
hey and uh Chad let me let me ask you
this
um
you mentioned just offhand that your dad
has dumped his entire retirement savings
into trying to save this house
is this house been a quagmire for a long
time
yeah we had a significant loss in the
family and we sold the original Family
Home and built this one and I don't
think my my family ever stopped and
grieved the loss of that loved one like
you guys always recommend stop and pause
for a year and they did this right
afterwards and and never slowed down and
it's just caught up with him now this
house has ghosts in it though right
yeah in that regard yeah so might be
moving the houses are something you talk
about sooner rather than later then I
might change my advice I I don't see a
situation where this house doesn't get
sold at some point and so I
man the sooner you get this Quagmire
just off your dad's neck man it just
feels like it's been weighing him down
for a long long time yeah let's begin to
clean up the mess she got plenty of cash
to live especially with a paid for 400
000 condo
you know and you got the you're in
position to do every bit of that the way
you're talking about running this down
um he's lucky to have you man yeah
you're a good man you got you got some
work to do there brother if we can help
further you call us anytime or call one
of our coaches we'll help you
this is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
on Black Friday nobody blames you I mean
you did miss out on some pretty good
deals maybe but so what
you know I think it's about to work out
in your favor because now you got Cyber
Monday right
and uh with us you can get prices as low
as five dollars on some of our
best-selling books and some of our tools
the deal that's going the fastest right
now is the 2023 goal planner the Ramsey
gold planner has been a big deal since
uh Christy Wright put it together a few
years ago and now it has moved uh into a
completely different thing with John
deloney and Rachel Cruz George Campbell
all in it and it is pretty incredible
it's an inspirational practical guide to
hitting your financial relational
spiritual goals in 2023 you'll get them
and for the first time ever it's on sale
get yours before they're gone if you're
looking for gifts for the women in your
life you got to check out the Rachel
Cruz wallet
it's handcrafted full grain leather with
a built-in cash envelope system
comes in four different colors and it's
a great gift for the lady who budgets
yeah it's on sale right now too it's a
deal this is the season to share the
hope we have with other people and if
you want to help them uh ten dollar
books are a great way to do that all the
stuff we've got for sale apparently we
forgot about inflation at Ramsey and
it's not here I went backwards we
decided not to participate I saw they
put on your past on sale today your book
for 12.99 shocking it is shocking I'm
supposed to at least get a year out of
it you guys man selling all of our books
it's fantastic uh I know I didn't even
get a year out of baby such millionaires
it was number one bestseller in January
here I sit in December it's already 10
bucks 10 bucks man there you go uh check
it out Cyber Monday one day sale today
ramseysolutions.com get them before
they're gone Marty's with us in Waco hi
Marty welcome to the Ramsey Show
yeah man I'm glad I could get a hold of
you you too glad you're here brother how
can we help
uh yes so I started listening uh
Thanksgiving uh last week and
um I'm essentially starting my baby step
Journey uh last two years I've kind of
restarted my life uh twice
and
um uh I might
have a son that's to be determined
hopefully by the end of the week
um so I'm just trying to you know
finally get my head straight and uh I
mean I didn't think about this even
before um
trying to establish a paternity it was
getting my head straight and I've been
making strides over the last few years
um in my life and I just Financial
stability is a big thing that I still
need to work on though
when you say you've restarted your life
twice over the last couple years what
does that mean
um
the long short story is uh I've been on
my own since I was 12 went to the
Marines and I did about seven years but
as soon as I got in the Marines I
essentially went back to just being as
Frugal and humble as I was before
because you know didn't really have any
major skill any formal formally trained
skills that I could put on resumes and
everything
um but I finally found a job who's
willing to get uh that was willing to
give me a chance and I've proven my soul
um and then uh
through that I thought I
um found uh so sorry
um whenever I came to this job I left my
hometown in San Antonio okay
um was living on the side of the road
for a month so I finally got money to
you know get a place
and then I heard of a job opportunity
that was supposed that did pay more back
home went back home but the cost of
living hit me again and went there for
my savings at San Antonio actually
Antonio okay so and uh you've woke up
and found yourself where are you living
right now
uh here um near Waco I'm about 45
minutes from Waco okay and you got a
good job
yes all right what do you mean I work
for the state so okay what do you make
31 000. okay and how old are you
26. okay so you're not homeless
you're stable you got a sustainable
situation
and it sounds like you got a girl
pregnant
uh yes okay and you're waiting to hear
about the uh paternity of the baby which
she is carrying correct or has been born
a year and a half old now
Okay so
uh uh and you're just hearing about this
why
uh I'm not just hearing about this uh
whenever we found out she was pregnant
um soon after she broke up with me and
uh she avoided all my attempts to reach
her so I could you know attempt to be
the father that
um I wanted to be
um and uh yesterday after church
um I decided
um I went by memory where her dad was
luckily I was able to find a place and I
was able to get back in touch with her
and she was finally willing to
compromise so yesterday we talked like
hey I want to order a home paternity
test and uh
um which I I'm gonna order today okay
I'm gonna step in and call bullcrap on
some of this okay
you have a legal right to your kid
and I want whether she tries to block or
not I want there to be a record so that
we already have recorded no no no no I
want there to be a track record let me
say that way so that one day when you
sit down eye to eye chest to chest with
this young son
I want you to be able to say I fought
for you I went to the ends of the Earth
for you I worked four jobs do what
I have a manila envelope of proving all
the texts and um
now listen listen whether this paternity
test proves Truth at the end of this
week or not
you're you've been going halfway
okay and it's time to fully step into
who you are gonna be
is that fair
yes of course and thankfully uh I've uh
we found a religion uh recently and
that's like I said I've been making
major strides in my life the last few
years
um you know telling you a better man
good so good good good sounds like you
got a lot of things heading in a
positive direction after
um a lot of circuit a lot of circling
the wagons back and forth back and forth
back and forth so yeah no good good for
you I'm glad for you yeah I'm proud for
you good good move you know so so run
this to ground find out with a paternity
test whether this is yours if it is
yours you're all in as a new dad like
you said and like John said you're gonna
make a record you're going to insert
yourself into the life of the child and
uh you're you've got to insert yourself
into the life of this church so you've
got some good men walking along beside
you and that can teach you things that
you've been looking for since you were
12. you found a few of them in the
Marines you'll find the rest of them in
the church
and which are skills on how to be a man
and uh you're learning that and there's
no harm there's no shame in the fact
that you're learning that uh now uh the
only shame will be is if you don't
bother to play through and to learn it
and we'll help you with the money piece
of it uh if you'll hang on I'm gonna
have the guys pick up and we're going to
sign you up for the best thing we have
which is Financial Peace University it's
nine weeks long and you can take the
lessons on how to handle money like a
grown-up uh like a boss and uh how to
not only get out of debt not only how to
live on what you make and start to
address your career issues with Ken
Coleman stuff if you want to as well I
mean if you'll come around all the
Ramsey stuff we'll walk with you in all
these different areas of your life yeah
I'll give you a copy of own your past
change your future as well yeah I want
you to read that book all the way
through we'll send you a a an audio link
too so if you're if you're not a reader
you can listen to it while you're
driving yeah because really there's a so
much to that idea right there in your
situation it is in everybody's life but
owning your past say this is what
happened
but it does not dictate my future that's
right and change your future so John's
book will be in the mix as well that we
give you we're going to load you up with
homework buddy it's all free
um the only problem is now you got to do
all the work
and we're here to help you call anytime
any of us will help you here with any
part of this but you're all in now it's
all looking forward going forward no
more circling
straight lines lots of straight lines
and I lean into the guys at that church
make them lean into your life and let
them speak into you this is the Ramsay
show
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
our scripture today Colossians 3 9 and I
have put on the new self which is being
renewed in knowledge after the image of
its creator
it's kind of for our last caller there
every person that's alive was endowed
with a brain that has the capacity to
change itself Dr Andrew huberman
uh Carolina Leaf stuff on that's very
interesting too and even um
our friend James on the atomic habits uh
James clear the uh the idea that you
reset your identity and say okay this is
not the thing I'm gonna do it's who I am
and that kind of person doesn't do that
that's right I am no longer an obese
person that eats too many donuts I
re-identified I actually had
um the doctor Elaine Norton is a friend
of mine uh
he called and challenged me on on my
show he said I gotta fact check you on a
thing on my one of my episodes and he
said you told somebody that you can't
control XYZ he said that's a story you
tell yourself that's simply not true and
we talked for 30 45 minutes he was right
he was right and I had fallen into like
so I do this for a living and I had
fallen into a trap of oh you're talking
about your gummy bears that's right
that's a choice he says you need to stop
telling yourself that now if choose to
tell yourself that but you can become a
person who doesn't do that and panties
right so the most interesting thing to
challenge you doctor Dr Leaf speaking at
uh entree I had never seen the actual
videos or of a thought that a thought
they have now proven I mean you can see
it it's the same video is a physical a
thought becomes a physical location in
the brain you can it's and you could
negative thoughts have different shapes
in the world than positive thoughts I
mean physically you can it's a thing you
it's not like a I always thought of
thoughts as like spiritual and they're
just in and The Ether and you know
they're like the internet you know or
whatever right but uh but no it turns
out thoughts have proteins and uh and
chemicals and they take shapes and they
look like a mushroom cloud of death if
it's a negative thought and if it's a
positive thought it's kind of pretty
it's so interesting it's pretty wild
very and you can just decide to replace
in your brain
you know the Bible talks about taking
every thought captive well there it is
you know and they have consequences
right I'm going to take this thought
captive and I'm just going to decide
that and that we have uh we have that
power and it is a uh the spiritual
guidance from scripture gives us that
power but it turns out that you know all
these years later now science is
actually proving what we already knew to
be true to be true I love the idea of
renewing your mind is not a thing that
not renewed but it's a thing that's
ongoing right I'm always working on my
thoughts and I'm always hoping iron
sharpenser and I got men in my life and
when in my life who would challenge me
and push me towards new ways of thinking
and new ways of being I love that well
five years from today you'll be the
person you are Charlie Jimenez Jones
said except for the books you read and
the people you may love it be the same
person you are today I love it and so
the thoughts and I'm going to decide I'm
going to control
uh you know the real you know people
talk about the real estate in your brain
you're getting rent free in your brain
that's a that's a thing it really is my
brain got expensive this past year it's
good
cost a lot to get up in there now you've
been a victim to some folk that's right
there's vacancy
it's expensive now
Bob is in many less hey Bob welcome to
the Ramsey Show
hey Dave uh so my question is I came
across this opportunity to buy a
multi-family apartment building cool in
a prime location I'm very tight with my
money and I'm constantly trying to come
up with different ways to make more
money aside from my full-time job as a
licensed electrician the only debt I
have is on my house
with 75 000 more to go
the price of the apartment will range
anywhere from 1 million to 1.5
the bank has approved me and my partner
on this deal and is contingent on the
rent roll
I know you guys like to pay cash for
things and so do I we only have about 10
to 15 percent for a down payment I'm
just an average guy that makes 75 000 a
year
and really want another source of income
do you think this is too much debt to
take on also if you were me how would
you tackle this process if I were to go
through with this deal
uh and we plan on using uh the positive
cash flow to pay down the debt on that
pretty aggressively
a couple of things on top of that well I
can stop you okay
okay let me just stop you gave me enough
information and
um here's the thing you've got uh you
got the fever really really bad
and um I've had the fever how old are
you
27 okay
um
I was 28 when I filed bankruptcy from
doing deals like this
exactly like this
and uh this D the steel is a bad idea
it's a bad idea because you're gonna
have a partner and you don't need a
partner number one it's a bad idea
because you're going to get in trouble
with a partner and he's going to leave
and then you're going to be left holding
the whole bag or he's going to start
doing drugs and you're going to be left
doing the whole bag or he's going to get
a divorce and move to Montana and you're
going to be left holding the whole bag
or whatever happens to stupid but
Partners you're going to learn the hard
way the only ship that won't sell as a
partnership the second thing is that
mathematically when you've leveraged
this thing as high as you've leveraged
it dude you've got no wiggle room here
if you get a 20 vacancy this thing will
bankrupt you
it won't carry itself because you got it
won't it won't service the debt you got
you got to keep it completely full and
operating like a maniac for with a 15
down an 85 percent leverage position 85
loan to value you can't keep this thing
cash flowing
um and and so no you're not a buyer for
this this is an opera this is not an
opportunity for you this is a nightmare
uh I don't know if I can talk you out of
it because you've got the fever so bad I
can feel the heat coming off your
forehead I know I just I feel like I
need to do something you don't yeah you
don't but don't don't do something
desperate and stupid okay because this
is this is this has got so many red
flags on it now someday I want you to
own some rental property that you pay
cash for I did deals like this I own
three million dollars worth and when I
was 28 I was bankrupt with a brand new
baby a toddler and a marriage Hanging On
by a thread I don't want that for you
and you're not just an average guy
making 75 000. uh you're a guy that
makes seventy five thousand dollars and
you're 27 years old and you've got the
ability to earn some money build some
wealth and own some paid for real estate
in the future and then it won't own you
and you won't have a partner screwing up
your life
and
um uh I don't know if there's any amount
of words I can say while I have you on
the phone to keep you from doing this
but if I could say them I would right
now
um so there is no equation under which
if I were you I would do this
there's you you are your mathematics are
out of whack on this you don't know what
the flip you're doing I own hundreds of
millions of dollars worth of real estate
and believe me you have vacancy you have
legal costs you have people that don't
pay and you have to remove them you have
people that beat their wife and you have
to remove them because they're in jail
you have all this crap that happens when
you own a multi-family like this and oh
and the heat and air goes out and it's
twenty five thousand dollars
and you don't have any money oh and then
the roof starts leaking oh and then
Coach comes by and says oh you know that
way you did the parking lot oh I didn't
do the parking lot the last owner did oh
doesn't matter you got to spend 60 000
bucks redoing that or we're going to
shut the whole freaking place down oh by
the way your light your electric meter
that you've got on this thing it's now
Antiquated and the electrician says he
won't work on it because it's dangerous
oh that's gonna be twenty six thousand
dollars
see this this is the crap that they
don't tell you about when they say your
renters are going to pay it off for you
your renters aren't going to pay it off
for you
you're going to pay it off or you're
going to go bankrupt in the process of
trying to hold on this thing so I hope I
said enough well I'll hold my beer Dave
there's the mass consequences here
let me tell you what else is going to
happen you're not going to sleep
you're not going to sleep for years
because that brain that is so desperate
to get an income a second income is also
going to be the same brain that's going
to recognize you are no longer safe
you're no longer in control of your
destiny if you get laid off everything
collapses your relationships are going
to suffer don't do this you're worth
more you're worth a non-anxious life man
and this is not it
foreign
[Music]
we'll be back with you before you know
it in the meantime remember there's
ultimately only one way to financial
peace and that's to walk daily with the
Prince of Peace Christ Jesus
[Music]
hey it's John deloney co-host of the
Ramsey show did you know over 18 million
people listen to the Ramsey show every
week a lot of those people listen on one
of our 600 plus radio stations across
the country to find a station near you
go to ramseysolutions.com show
foreign
[Music]